ce nouveau gouvernement élargi à 42
membres nommés aujourd'hui est
totalement paritaire si l'on compte la
première ministre vingt-et-une femmes
pour 21 hommes dans ce nouveau
gouvernement il ya ceux qui restent mais
qui changent de poste comme olivier
ferrand qui passent des relations avec
le parlement au porte parolat allégées
-sans d'amandes de france de frustration
évidemment à se dire qu'il nous faut
chacun quitter un ministère où nous
commencions à peine à prendre nos
marques on sait qu'olivier ferrand a été
un ministre très contesté il a pris des
décisions tout à fait contestable que
nous continuions à contester moi je ne
me réjouis pas de le voir au
gouvernement mais il n'est plus
relations avec le parlement s'était
absolument compliqué de travailler avec
lui en ce qui concerne les ministères
dits régaliens ou d'importance comme
l'économie ou l'éducation nationale tous
ceux qui étaient dans le premier
gouvernement d'elisabeth bornes sont
reconduits je suis certain que les
français voudraient voir et notamment
ceux qui ont voté pour les l'air ou pour
les socialistes par exemple ce serait
mort comme travaillons ensemble pour
leur bien et pas dans des chamailleries
politiques face à ce remaniement est
bien les oppositions à tire à boulet
rouge en dehors d'un jeu de chaises
musicales on reste dans une épure qui
est tout à fait la même avec des
ministres qui sont globalement bien
connu un petit virage à droite on prend
les mêmes et on recommence
et c'est pas avec des petites taches de
couleurs que l'on met dans un
gouvernement comme sur un tableau que
l'on donne des signes d'ouverture on
remplace des techno que personne ne
connaît par d'autres techno que personne
ne connaît c'est la récompense de
l'échec on dit souvent que la vie
politique se construit dans l'es17 c'est
ma première elle est rude visé par une
enquête pour tentative de viol damien
abad a finalement été écarté du
gouvernement après une discussion avec
le président de la république était
préférable faso calomnie ignoble dont je
suis la cible orchestrée dans un
calendrier bien choisi jusqu'à ce matin
encore que je puisse le défendre sans
entraver l'action du gouvernement accusé
de viol dans le cadre de sa précédente
activité de gynécologues crise où la
zacharopoulos
elle en poste chargé du développement et
de la francophonie ce remaniement marque
aussi le retour de marlène schiappa
l'ancien ministre délégué à la
citoyenneté sera en charge de l'économie
sociale et solidaire et de la vie
associative
conseil des ministres cet après midi à
16 heures avec les 42 membres du nouveau
gouvernement bornes
l'exécutif veut se montrer au travail
après des semaines de flottement et un
remaniement express ce matin emmanuel
macron prévient ses trous dans ce
contexte vous aurez d'abord à tenir
tenir dans ce contexte de guerre qui
changent en profondeur beaucoup de
choses et je pense que ça n'a pas été
suffisamment intégré dans le débat
public français la france insoumise
me paraît plus toxiques aujourd'hui que
leur congrès national pour un groupe qui
s'appelle renaissance ça fait surtout le
sentiment d'avoir des gens qui
reviennent d'avoir des come back et ça
symbolise in fine et je pense l'impasse
dans laquelle se trouve emmanuel ma cour
cette fameuse nubes a inscrit à son
propre à à son programme l'abrogation de
la loi séparatisme et donc
l'antisémitisme sa terre d'asile ce
n'est plus leur assemblée nationale
c'est la france insoumise sur ces images
on découvre l'impressionnante masse qui
s'est décroché du glacier de la
marmolada hier c'est un torrent de glace
de bruit de roche qui a déferlé sur les
flancs de la montagne
cet effondrement est lié vous l'avez
compris à la vague de chaleur et à la
sécheresse historique qui affecte
l'italie depuis plusieurs semaines le
déficit de pluviométrie de plus de 50%
provoque une crise inédite un vélo à 2,2
me roux derrière l'objet se cache un
ingénieur qui aime les défis est ce
compliqué à l'arrivée son vélo roule
parfaitement et sans actrice une
prouesse pour ce bricoleur déjà
inventeur du vélo sans rayons et du
beaucoup plus dangereux overboard sur
place